Transcriber: Dilara AL
Gözden geçirme: Yiğit Yıldırım
Evet, bir hikaye var.
Baba her şeyden şikayet eden oğluna bir
şeyler öğretmek için önüne üç tane
malzeme koyar.
Patates, yumurta ve kahve.
Ondan sonra da der ki işte üçünü
birer tane kaba koy.
Yirmi dakika pişir.
Bak bakalım ne oluyor?
Hakikaten yirmi dakika pişirdikten
sonra da çocuğa sorar ne oldu?
Çocuk der ki pişti bunlar.
Yani bir şey olmadı ki.
Baba der ki yanlış düşünüyorsun.
Patates sertti, piştikten
sonra içi yumuşadı.
Yumurtanın içi yumuşaktı.
Bu sefer o kaynar suyu gördükten
sonra sertleşti.
Kahve kendi halinde hiç tadı yoktu.
Yenebilir durumda değildi.
Şimdi suya bütün rahiyasını bıraktı.
Hayat senin altındaki suyu pişirmeye
başladığı zaman sen ne yapacaksın?
Şimdi etrafımızda bazı insanlar vardır,
öyle çok eğlencelidirler.
Sürekli her şeye gülerler,
her şey onlar için komiktir,
eğlencelidir, bazıları vardır
hayat onlara ne yaparsa yapsın gene
ayakta kalmayı becermişlerdir.
Burada örnekleri gördük.
Baktığınızda mesela benim favori
örneklerimden bir tanesi bu.
Çünkü Steve Jobs aslında Macintosh batmaya
başladığı zaman kendi yönetim kurulu
tarafından işten kovulup
Sonra Pixar’ı kurup Pixar’ı Disney’e
sattıktan sonra o batmakta olan Macintosh
alıp tekrar Mac haline getirip şimdi
dünyanın en pahalı ve popüler
bilgisayarının üreten firmayı yapmış kişi.
Bir de başka insan tipleri de vardır öyle.
Bugün enerji soğuran diyorlar
ya onlardan böyle.
Benim bir tane öyle arkadaşım var mesela.
Bu değil.
Bu benim arkadaşım değil buna
uygun örnek diye koydum.
Ama böyle yarım saat yanında oturun.
Hakikaten beraber köprüye
giderseniz öyle düşünün.
Şimdi ben olaylara tabii fizik öğretmeni
olarak biraz daha farklı bir açıdan
bakmak istiyorum.
Şimdi şöyle bir şey düşünebiliriz.
Bir kazak, mesela bu kazak kırmızı renkli.
Niye?
Kırmızı olduğu için mi? Hayır.
Fizikte bir şeyin rengi aslında ona düşen
ışığı yansıtması ile belli olur.
Dolayısıyla bu kazak aslında
kırmızı değil.
Kırmızıyı yansıtıyor veya diğer kazaklar.
Baktığınızda niye diğerleri
farklı renklerde?
Çünkü aynı ışık onların üzerine
düşmesine rağmen
onlar da kendi renklerini yansıtıyorlar.
Şimdi günlük hayat hepimiz için
üç aşağı beş yukarı
benzer şeyleri içeriyor olabilir.
Sabah yani hepimiz, anne-babamız,
çoluğumuz, çocuğumuz, kardeşimiz
gülümseyerek bizi karşılıyor.
Işte ne bileyim sabah metroya binerken
arkadaki adam omuz atıyor,
ondan sonra giderken trafik, işte
biri emniyet şeridinden gidiyor.
Yahu bunların hepsi bizim
başımıza mı geliyor?
İşe yetişmek lazım.
Yarısı yenmiş simit, çay falan.
Her şey başımıza kötü mü geliyor?
Veya sadece bizim başımıza mı geliyor?
Bakın benim kişisel düşüncelerimden
bir tanesi şu.
Bunlar hepimizin başına
Aşağı yukarı baktığımızda aslında benzer
şekilde hepimizin başına geliyor.
Biz hangisini yansıtıyoruz?
Ve başımıza bunca
olumsuz şey geldiği zaman
biz hep gölgelerin arasında mı
kalmayı tercih edeceğiz?
Niye gölge?
Çünkü ışık yansımadığı zaman, daha
doğrusu herhangi bir obje ışığı
yansıtmıyorsa siyah renkli olur.
Orası gölge kısmı.
Şimdi buraları geçelim.
Bu çalışıyor mu bilmiyorum.
Evet, şimdi bu çok hoşuma giden
sözlerden bir tanesi.
Bir şeyi yapabilirim diyen kişi ile
yapamam diyen kişilerin ikisi de
eşit derecede haklıdır.
Bu yüzden,
Yani işler her zaman kolay mıydı?
Einstein o efsanevi denklemi işte
E=mc²’yi öyle mi buldu mesela?
Hayat ona hep mi kolaydı?
Hayır, her zaman çalıştı.
Yetenek.
Evet, yetenek doğuştan geliyor
olabilir ama
Beceri saatlerce, saatlerce,
saatlerce çalışma sonucunda ortaya çıkar.
Biraz önce örneğinde gördük zaten.
Eğer.
İşler sizin için kolay gidiyorsa
o zaman gelişmiyorsunuz demektir.
O kan, ter, gözyaşı falan diyorlar ya,
gelişebilmek için işte bunlara
ihtiyacınız var.
Bunlar olmadan hayat çok kolay olur.
Hepimizin önünde ya işte bu adamda çok
kolay para kazanıyor
dediğiniz insanların olduğunu biliyorum.
Ama o insanların kendileri
yüzyıl önce da vardı.
Bugün hiçbirini anmıyoruz bile.
Gerçekten çalışıp çaba gösterip bir yere
gelebilen insanları bugün biliyoruz.
Mesela çok sevdiğim örneklerden
bir tanesi
1927 Solvay konferansı
fotoğrafını görüyorsunuz.
Burada zeka seviyesi böyle
stratosferlerde falan
Atmosferi aşmış vaziyette.
Ama bu burada mesela bir tane kadın var:
Madam Curie.
Einstein’ın iki tane
sol tarafında.
Bu kadının hayatı mesela
zorluklarla geçmiş bütün hayatı.
Ve bu konferansta bu kadınla,
o çok zeki diye gördüğümüz adamlar
Arkada işte Schrödinger’ler,
Bohr’lar falan konuşmuyorlar.
Bilimde kadının yeri yok diye.
Bir tek Einstein konuşuyor.
Biraz çapkın ama onun dışındakilerin
tamamı konuşmuyorlar.
Bu kadının hayatı inanılmaz zorluklarla
geçiyor ama o yüzden Madam Curie o zaten.
O yüzden tekrar söylemek istiyorum.
Bir şeyi yapabilirim diyen kişiyi ile
yapamam diyen kişilerin ikisi de
eşit derecede haklıdır.
Siz hangisini seçeceksiniz?
Teşekkür ederim.